as Will Smith said parents just don't
understand I made their kids Kentucky
Child Protective Services has seized him
family's 10 children after they were
reportedly found living in makeshift
tents in a tiny cabin on a garbage dump
according to a police report the family
was residing in attend the mother had
given birth in a tent there is no
running water or septic and none of the
children were enrolled in school
numerous piles of garbage broken glass
and nails were also scattered about the
property as well as a pond that had no
barrier around it to prevent the
children from entering or falling in the
parents are sticking to their guns about
their alternative lifestyle saying the
authorities are punishing them for
embracing a free-range approach to
parenting which gives children total
independence from infancy the couple has
created a GoFundMe page which has
amassed more than thirty thousand
dollars in donations alright so I'm very
conflicted about this story we just did
a segment a second ago about
microchipping kids and what that can
lead to and then you see instances like
this where they're doing this free-range
parenting thing I'm not a huge fan of
government overreach I'm a libertarian
in many ways so I don't like the
government getting involved in forcing
everyone to do everything however if
these kids were you know around a pond
that was dangerous and there was broken
glass and they're not being bathed and
there's other health issues okay I get
it is there a happy balance between
basically being this family and being
the microchip freaks yeah i mean i don't
think that they're doing it right you
know i think that when you hear things
like broken glass around like that's
just I don't think there's any excuse
you know it seems like they're almost
doing it for attention you were saying
right before like yeah I my I'm not on
their side I think that the fact that
we're now looking at this issue I think
it's because i love the government and
you want the government any bother every
decision in everyone know well like but
it doesn't seem like the kids are it
doesn't seem like it's a safe
environment for them you know alright so
now we obviously don't know every
specific about this family in one of the
pictures at least on the go fund me page
they look pretty put together and then
we saw some stuff where it looked like
they were literally like in dirt or hoop
or something um where do you follow that
like how involved the government should
be
and you know making sure people are
doing the right things with their kids
I'm with Max on the broken glass that
seemed sketchy to me but what I have
kids I want them to look like those kids
with dirt on their face I want my kids
to be living in the soil yeah parenting
life not living some synthetic clothes
you know in clothes life when I heard
the section on the on the report there
that talked about how the ponds didn't
have an enclosure around it that made my
blood boil a little bit yeah because I
mean come on there is a certain limit we
have to let kids roam free it's at a
certain point so this family has got it
right to some extent but you're right
broken glass adverse poverty the kids
could probably be leaving a little
better than that yeah but I mean you
know you see people you know families in
the developing world living in tents all
the time and fine i'm not you know
there's no judgment passed but like this
particular family isn't in a network of
other families that are doing that and
you know a system hasn't emerged they're
just kind of like it seems like they're
winging it it's not safe it's not clean
this desire for people to get off the
grid I do respect the the idea that's
going on here that they want their kids
as you're saying they want them to grow
up with something a little bit different
and not be staring at the phones all the
time and every black mirror episode and
all that so I respect all that stuff and
yet at the same point something seems
off here where how do you draw the line
of where someone should get involved is
its health basically yeah well I mean at
least let's look at how we treat this
time position of the situation of the
developing world they have to have
certain minimum standards by which we
can we can call that a healthy family
the kids have to have access to the
proper amount of nutrition proper access
to health care certain levels of
education if they're doing all of those
things to whatever minimum requirement
we have set for them in whatever state
they live then beyond that let them do
whatever they want do you guys think the
off-the-grid movement is like the next
big thing that more and more people are
trying to do this yeah I think like
companies like tesla are definitely like
facilitating that so I think I mean I
definitely think it's a positive thing
for society and you know truth be told
those kids are probably pretty healthy
because they're you know they're they
were probably born naturally they're
probably you're there playing in the
dirt you know amongst healthy you know
micro biomes or immune systems are
probably better than your average person
born in a sterile environment via
c-section they probably know a lot more
about sir
ival the average four-year-old right
that thing amor Jerry yeah so I'm not
hating it's just when you read things
about like the broken glass that's
happening on a garbage dump you know
that's where my radar it goes off just
don't raise your kids in a garbage dump
and then besides that do what you got to
do anyway what do you think let us know
in the comments right